all right everyone what's happening this
is Sam so on today's pod I did something
very selfish so I've got these two
friends one is named Nick bear so you
probably have seen Nick on Instagram or
on YouTube he's got millions of
followers and he owns this company
called bpn bare performance nutrition
they do something like $60 million a
year in sale so he's a really successful
entrepreneur but he's like a fitness
fanatic so he looks like a bodybuilder
but he's runs some marathon in like 2
hours and 39 minutes which is a freakish
time but it's also freakish considering
how big he is and then we have sahill
Bloom who's another buddy of mine who's
really popular on social media on
Twitter he's a writer you probably have
seen him all over the place and I just
nerded out on Fitness with these guys we
also talked a little bit about business
so we asked the typical questions like
where do you guys spend your money how
much you spend each month where do you
like to invest your money um we talked
about their their companies and how
they're growing and we did a lot of
business stuff but most of this was
about Fitness and I just asked them all
the fitness questions that I had I had a
bunch of listeners send me questions and
I think it was a great time and it was
really fun to learn about what these
guys are doing for training hopefully
inspire you so anyway check out the
[Music]
Pod can I ask you so I I tweeted out
that you guys were coming on and I got a
bunch of questions they range from
personal finance Fitness business all
types of stuff I want to ask you guys
both a couple questions I'm going to
start which I'm going to start with one
that sounds like the hardest but I
actually think it's the easiest because
you answer this all the time and I'll
preface this by saying I've seen your
your father in videos I've seen your
brother in videos and I've seen you in
real life and so I think I know what the
answer is because I know the genetics
that you come from but someone said
genuinely curious how can Nick be
natural given his performance please
press him on this and so you constantly
get asked if you're natural I know
you've answered it constantly but just
humor me for because this was a a very
uh a lot of people ask this question
I am
natural and I used to address these
these call outs and questions and claims
all the time because I would get
defensive in it like it was all the time
it's been like that since I started
creating
content I even went to the extent of
sharing blood work every month I was
going getting blood work every month and
I would share it on my videos during my
bulk in my cut and people like oh he's
faking he's F he's finding workarounds
I'm like guys
so I finally have gotten to a point
where I'm just over addressing the the
questions and the claims and the hate
around it and I'm just gonna do my thing
like even in this last marathon people
were like he's using EPO what is that
like blood doping I'm like what amateur
what amateur athlete you know that's
running marathons run marathons is
taking EPO and blood doping but then
you're like but how do I how do I get
that does anyone have a guy like yeah
I'm like who like where do you get
EPO I don't even know where you you
you'd get that um I I mean I've seen you
uh in real life that you you just have I
think you're just a freak genetically
and and I I would be honored if someone
asked if I was on a bunch of stuff that
would make me feel wonderful Dude also
by the way like my um my thing with this
always is like I have a few friends who
everyone says this about they're like oh
they you know definitely not natural and
I just know for a fact that that person
has just outworked me in the gym on a
daily basis for the last like 10 [__]
years excuse my language and not by like
a ton but by a little bit every single
day for 10 years and that adds up to
something insane and it looks like a
totally different human being so like
when I see a dude that has way bigger
shoulders than me or way bigger chest
like I know that they probably did that
extra set or they did the extra two reps
that I was just like oh six is good and
stopped and so like I just I think it's
such a cop out when people freak out
about like oh are you natural or not the
reality is like sometimes they don't
because genetics are real like for
example genetics are real but genetics
are like definitely a real thing like
the the bare genetics are solid dude
your dad ran like a sub Six Mile I don't
remember what age he is but he was some
you know he was a grown man and he still
was huge like you got and then I saw
your brother your brother looked like he
competed in the strongman games I mean
you guys are just huge yes my my dad's
60 my uncle his brother is 57 if you saw
both of them with their shirts off after
running they've still both run marathons
half marathons I mean six-pack abs
chiseled arms and shoulders they don't
take anything they're not they're not on
trt or any of that stuff they're just
like Farm boys who grew up in central
Pennsylvania milking cows and and
bailing hay dude listen to this so
sahill texted me I I I nerded out with
them I go this I go dude I just hung out
with Nick bear um and and it was amazing
and sahill was like yeah he's you know
he looks great whatever but how tall is
he and I was like I'm pretty sure he's
my height or just like an inch shorter
uh so he's pretty tall and I sent him
this picture and I remember in that
photo I think I think Nick you were at
like your weakest you're were about to
run a marathon I was at my strongest and
our squats and bench were like almost
the same I think you did five pounds
ahead and um you just like looked so
much better and you know we were like
the sucks that like we're kind of
comparable I guess in terms of strength
but like he just he just has it he just
has it like you you just you just have
whatever it is that you just you look
good uh appreciate that genetics are
real AR's laughing at mean helps Sam you
got Sam you got to get a tan man you're
too pale to uh you're too pale to have
good-looking ABS That's genetics man
it's that's another genetics component
he just has it and so I don't know
everyone everyone in the comments are
going to make fun of me that I'm just
like flirting with you but you know I'm
just saying what people think
genetics are like a real thing you can
take person a person B different
genetics same work ethic same diet same
training program and you're not going to
get the same results people people send
me messages all the time they're like I
eat exactly what you eat I train exactly
way you train I run exactly the same
miles as you but we don't look the same
yeah because genetically we are not the
same like we have different DNA so it's
going to have different results it
doesn't mean you shouldn't eat right and
train and and try to do your best but
like I will give I will give genetics
the credit they deserve but also I am
one of the most consistent people I know
in terms of training and recovery and
diet like my diet is dialed in I still
enjoy myself like me and my wife will go
for dinner I'll get some drinks I'll
like order the whole menu and try
everything I love food I'm a big foodie
but my my diet 90% of the time time is
so regimented and dialed in I'm eating
my meals when I'm not hungry I'm eating
my meals when I know I need nutrition to
fuel workouts like it is for me a
lifestyle that I truly love and
embrace I can't find this client info
have you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a
CRM platform so it shares its data
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
or dueling databases HubSpot grow better
are you like that sill are you as dial
you think yeah I mean I'm just like I
probably have a similar wiring to you n
like I kind of have like a obsessive
personality and so when I when I commit
to something or dive in on it it's going
to piss off everyone around me because
I'm like if we were traveling during the
day and I get home at 10 p.m but I had a
six mile run to do I'm going out at 10
p.m. and have to go hit the run and it's
not a question and like if I get home at
midnight but I'm the type of person that
wakes up at 4 and gets in my cold plunge
I'm waking up at 4 and getting in my
cold plunge and uh I'm I feel the same
way as you in General on the genetics
thing although I will say like when
people say oh I do the same workouts as
you I run the same miles I did the same
thing I call [__] because I I just
don't
like i' I've trained super hard my whole
life but there are people that I just
know have trained harder than me because
I know like in the back of my mind I
know for sure that like I could have
probably done two more reps on something
but I like was working out on my own and
my in my home gym and I just like took
it easy and that two reps compounded
over five years makes a difference um to
the point I'm like time being a lever
and so I'm honest enough with myself on
some things where like with running I
post all my stats and so there's no
hiding right like if I'm gonna post my
koros you know screenshot or whatever on
my Instagram from any run workout I
can't hide from whether or not I put in
the right amount of effort on that
workout but lifting I can totally hide
from it I'm not sh you can't see all the
stats exactly on what I did and how many
reps I hit or whatever it was and so
it's also just like the accountability
um that comes with sharing things
publicly on your progress that I feel
like for you like you've been basically
doing that for what six seven eight
years like you've been showing your
process in public and the accountability
that comes from that that people are out
there waiting like oh what's next next
thing what's he going after is he gon to
hit his goal that adds a whole lot of
fire like when you're running Sim sure
and you're struggling mile 20 and you're
like this isn't for this isn't for me
like I I have a million people out there
that want to see me get this 239 done so
I'm gonna go do it I mean that's that's
why we included a small clip in the
video after that race was over but
that's why these when you hit your goal
in a
race or you hit your goal in anything it
feels so good when you hit it cuz you
know the work that went in and all I
kept saying after I got across that
Finish Line at cim
I kept saying man I'm so [__] proud
of that I'm so proud of that one because
like you know all the work that goes
into it the early mornings hitting your
workouts making sure you hit your your
Paces making sure you fueled properly
the night before those big workouts and
when I was at like mile 20 I knew I was
I was running sub 240 like I I just knew
I was on Pace like I can hold on for
another six miles I could feel this lump
just like forming in my throat was
getting emotional
so I was thinking man all this work like
this is why I did it I'm holding 605
Paces at Mile 20 with six miles left
like home stretch and when you finally
hit that goal and it's because of the
work you put in like there's nothing
that replaces
that my um my dad and I have been really
close my whole life and I played
baseball in college Nick in case in case
we we hadn't talked about about that and
um when I had to retire cuz I was hurt
the hardest thing was telling my dad um
cuz so much of our relationship had been
built around the sport and built around
you know him coming to all my practices
taking me to all my lessons all that
stuff over the years and he told me at
the time like I don't care I'm gonna be
there to cheer you on and whatever your
next thing is in life and at my Marathon
uh he surprised me and flew out for it
and I remember like those last six miles
I was hurting so so bad and all I was
thinking the whole time was like I got
to get to my dad he's at the Finish Line
he's there waiting for me and when I
crossed the finish line and I had done
it I'd gone sub three he was standing
there and I like broke down completely I
like all of the emotion that you hold in
from that you know from trying to get to
something from like struggling through
it hitting your goal um that emotion
like it's completely unparalleled like
nothing I've ever experienced in life
just that that rush I think it's why
people keep signing up and and doing
races or signing up and committing to
hard things is cuz when you finally
accomplish it it's like uh I referenc
this part of this book all the time
because I think it's so applicable but
in Tim Grover's book winning he talks
about achieving your first win and when
you achieve that first win no matter
what it is it builds this little ounce
of
confidence so then you set down to
achieve another win but that win is
larger and more ambitious and it
requires more work more effort but when
you finally get it builds more
confidence and you keep applying this
thing over years and years and years and
you keep pushing out what that win is
and could be through the process of
succeeding and failing and winning and
losing you build this massive amount of
confidence where you finally get to a
point thinking oh I can actually do
whatever I want to do that's a really
powerful position to be in that's why I
always say there's no such thing as a
loser who wakes up at 5:00 a.m. and
works out because it is so hard to do
and if you are losing in life and you're
not happy with where you are get up
early and work out I hate when you say
that you piss me off so much when you
say that because I get out of bed at 7
or eight but I'll be doing stuff until
1:00 am whenever you see that I feel so
guilty but that is I'm not saying it on
the other end that you can't win I'm
saying if you're not happy with your
position in life one of the biggest
reasons is that you need to change your
self identity right like you need to
start identifying as a winner exactly
what Nick said like you need to create
evidence that proves to yourself that
you're a winner and waking up early and
working out is the easiest way to do
that and like it still sucks but if you
do that for a week you immediately are
like oh wow I can do that that's one
hard thing that I do I'm like you start
to change your brain chemistry around
who you are as a person dude I feel so
shitty I'll wake up I'll look at
Instagram and I'll be like all right I
just got up at 8 and then I see Nick
post and it's like I think on Saturday
or something it's like dude he just ran
ran eight miles he already just ran 72
miles at a 615 Pace he like his
Instagram post I'm and fed his daughter
a great meal yeah like he does all this
I'm even awake but in my head I'm like
that [__] is going to bed at nine
though I'm I'm gonna [__] him up between
10 10 and 1: a.m I I am I am a morning
person I am not a night owl by any means
but now now my daughter's born and she's
getting older if I don't wake up at 5:
and work out there's a chance it's it
might not get done so like right now
we're going through this sleep
regression where she's waking up at the
oddest times and screaming her head off
in the night so like last night woke up
middle of the night gave her a bottle
put her down she didn't want me to leave
her room so I ended up sleeping the rest
of the night next to her crib my alarm
went off at 5 I was like all right here
we go went downstairs went through my
routine went out for my
run there's nothing that makes me more
sick to my stomach than morning air um
let me ask you guys let me ask you guys
a quick question um this will be it's
met for Nick but S I want to hear your
answer too Nick covers all Fitness and
diet stuff extensively on his channel
but I want to know his monthly burn so
where what he spends his money on and
where he puts his money invest his money
outside of
BPM so investing
wise at this point in my life I haven't
gotten to a point where I have any
personal interest in investing so I just
hire a financial adviser and he takes
care of all of my investment for me
maybe at some point I'll actually be
curious and explore that Curiosity but
like I work with a guy we make a budget
funds probably yeah I'm just like take
this money put it where you think it's
gonna make me some
money uh other than that I mean most of
my money I'm spending is either going
towards my
mortgage investing back into the
business my personal
brand and mainly food to be honest like
me and my wife how you spend per month
on food just groceries maybe
like it's hard to say because we'll do
like one big grocery Hall week then I go
like every other day to the grocery
store and I'm going to like these
exclusive like butcher shops here in
Nashville so maybe I spend
$2,251 a month on groceries but then
we're going out to dinner and like when
we go out to dinner it's we want every
appetizer every entree we're going to
sample stuff getting a few cocktails
like we our thing is we love sure
experiences like that and we'll do some
big vacations every year like I'm not
going out and buying a lot of
materialistic things right now it's more
so on experiences so you haven't gotten
on the no alcohol train Nick nope uh to
be honest like I I really have no
interest on the the no alcohol train
like I'm not a big drinker but like if
me and my wife are going to date night
on Thursday because Thursday is our date
night night I'll get one drink maybe two
drinks but I really really never drink
over two
drinks ever wait do you drink
sahill I'm the same way as Nick like I I
um I think like when it enhances the
experience with the person you're with
uh I love it and then I just I've cut
all like drink by myself at home out of
my life yeah I don't do any drinking by
myself but like if I'm with a group of
people and we're having like a an
oldfashioned or opening a bottle of wine
I do think it enhances the experience
and conversation's always good and it
lightens the mood a little bit and just
allows you
to
relax what what's your St what's your
answer to that question what do you what
do you do you do with your money the
same thing I do you just are in Vanguard
index right yeah I mean we were like I
was much more fun with my money when I
was in my private Equity days uh cuz
then it was like like I don't know I was
just like freewheeling in my 20s doing
whatever the hell and then we had a kid
and I was like I should probably start
just being really boring with this and I
feel like you influenced me in this like
we're in this group chat all together
with a bunch of uh absolute degenerates
and they all like sling their money into
the most degenerate stuff and they're
always texting the thread like this is
the best new opportunity buy like a
million dollars of aluminum or a million
dollars of some some [__] that i' never
even heard of and without fail by the
way like 6 months later it's at its
alltime low like this thing just
absolutely tanks yeah it's stupid or
they'll short stuff or whatever I don't
even know what they do but it's like
these the terminology that I don't even
understand I mean it goes back to like
the fundamental thing is like you should
spend more time figuring out how to
increase your income versus like what
your returns are investing for the vast
majority of people because that's a much
bigger lever for your long-term
Financial wealth um that's what I did
for a while I just
I just focused on how to make more money
how to how to build revenue streams and
then it got to a point where like I was
finally ready to start investing and I
was able to invest or put away a lot of
money a month that I didn't need to
spend or or have liquid yeah and it's
just like I just like to not have to
think about where that is though like
yeah I do that too I just want it to sit
and like I basically want to just track
an index and just go sit there but to
the burn question Sam we probably spend
like I don't know 20 30 a month or
something like that um all in on
everything and groceries probably
similar to similar to Nick we probably
spend three to five a month um on food I
don't even know I don't know what my
monthly spend is at the moment but maybe
20 but I can see why New York would be
significantly higher but I you're about
to get on the uh Northeast grind right
yeah I'm thinking about moving up there
and I'm looking at the difference in
prices and like it's it's uh it's pretty
meaningful compared to Texas uh yeah you
are you think about going to the city so
my in-laws live uh around in this in
Manhattan and I frankly hate Manhattan I
like Brooklyn but I have a newborn and I
think that we will likely do the most
bougie thing on Earth but um there's a
town called the Westport Connecticut
it's next to greenage Connecticut so you
could say I'm going to move to Greenwich
Connecticut which is like clay clay ten
courts and white skirts and [__] like
that but I think we're going to yeah but
we like I I'm testing it out so I rented
a place for uh a few weeks uh in late
January just to see what it's like and
I'm looking at what the rent is and like
a comparable home to where I am now
because I don't want to buy at the
moment it's like 20 grand a month in
rent I mean it's just like crazy uh so
the biggest Reason by the way that Sam's
not saying for why he's moving here is
because it's like 20 minutes from me and
we have a long-term plan of my son Roman
and his daughter Naomi uh starting to
build the uh the par Bloom Empire here
so we need to like start cultivating it
early in their in their young years yeah
I'm okay with that uh we're we're just
planning ahead um let right let me ask
you guys another question um uh uh this
is a two-parter so what what do most
people get wrong about health and
fitness what makes you want to Nick what
makes you want to throw your computer
out the window and people say it online
and the second thing is um would love an
honest assessment of time requirements
and what's the best bang for your buck
for workouts because a lot of us
listening are entrepreneurs and we don't
have a ton of time um so what's like the
best bank for your buck so it's a
two-parter I think they I can answer
both probably in one answer I think most
people think that they need to spend
like an hour running a day and an hour
strength training a day so everyone
thinks they have to spend like two hours
training a day and I think you could
easily split that
45 minutes to an hour a day split
between strength and endurance training
and get like a really really solid
workout but I think you have some sort
of you have to have some sort of level
of cardiovascular conditioning as well
as strength into your programming when
you say cardiovascular do you mean like
hit like a like a 60-minute berries or
do you mean like a like a berries boot
camp class something like that or a body
weight thing or do you mean walking or
do you mean zone two steady Pac stuff
I'd say it's a mixture between Zone 2
Zone 3 cuz most people to be honest
aren't spending their time in zone two
zone two is actually like super low and
which is like what 130 beats per minute
for like a 30y old yeah it's it's it's
low and most people are not doing any
zone two training so I I like what's the
benefit of zone two though aerobic Base
building but what's that mean for does
that make me live longer does that make
me less likely to have a heart attack
what's it do all those things helps uh
cardiovascular health it helps build
your aerobic foundation so that you can
utilize oxygen more efficiently like
you're not going to go run a sub three
hour marathon by just doing speed workor
you need that aerobic Base building
where your body is learning how to
utilize the oxygen at a more effective
and efficient rate by then using fuel
sources appropriately alongside
of so like I'd say a split between you
probably want just talking about
cardiovascular conditioning 70 to 80% of
that training being your aerobic Zone
whether that's zone two zone three which
is like lighter so you're walking hiking
jogging something like that and then 20
to 30% of your cardiovascular
conditioning more hit you go do a
Berry's boot camp you can go do like a
my my wife does soul cycle like a soul
cycle class hop on your pelaton go do
some Sprints speed workout something
like that where the heart rate is
getting
elevated uh lactate threshold type stuff
so if you split your your cardiovascular
training between aerobic zones and some
high-intensity interval training and
then you have compound movements
strength training you're doing some some
heavier movements working with free
weights barbells machines stuff like
that you don't need to spend two hours
every day you can spend 45 minutes to an
hour you know four days a week five days
a week I personally love the train so I
I'm working out every day a week doing
something move my body for strengthening
what do you what do you say is like do
you tell people like do the five by five
or like what what's your suggestion just
squat deadlift bench what do you do I
mean there's a lot of different ways to
approach it like right now I personally
enjoy the pushpull leg split which is a
a three-day split you can do three
workouts a week or you can do six
workouts a week so like a push day would
be all pushing movements it'd be chest
focused shoulders triceps pushing being
upper body and then a pool day would be
back biceps movements like rows all
upper body again and then your lower day
is um lower body legs quads hamstrings
glutes I like starting every strength
workout with some some warm-up movements
and then going into a a heavy working
compound movement exercise like a
barbell squat you do a deadlift you can
do a hex barar deadlift bench press or
dumbbell chest press and then having
some accessory movements alongside of
that to support the development of the
muscles that you're utilizing for those
big compound movements so that's the way
I like to
approach cardiovascular and then
strength training I don't personally
like to mix the two like the CrossFit
approach I've never fallen in love with
that like when I'm strength training I
like strength training and when I'm
doing my cardio I like cardio but I
don't I don't like like doing them
together I like when they're separate
and distinct and
separated now moving on to I think where
like what irks me about the fitness
space I actually made a post about this
yesterday because everyone going into a
new year is going to have new training
and diet goals then everyone thinks like
there's this new thing that they're
going to do that's going to change their
life it's going to change their body
it's going to change their health so
January 1 starts people are thinking I
need to do something new what should I
do I'm gonna do carnivore no I'm gonna
do keto I'm G I'm gonna go like strictly
bodybuilding no I'm just like just GNA
run so people go to these extremes
thinking it's like the magic pill they
haven't tried yet that's going to unlock
this hidden potential that was just
disguised by everything else they were
doing previous VI ly and the reality is
that like that's not going to change
anything if it does like the the changes
are incremental but what makes this
compounding change in your life in your
Fitness is your health is just being
consistent with eating better drinking
more water moving your body that's why
everyone's talking about getting in more
steps when you're getting in more steps
you're just being more active going to
the gym on a regular consistent basis
it's creating
creating habits and routines in your
life that help you facilitate these
healthy habits on a consistent and
regular routine Sean was telling me that
he was talking or he saw the guy who
started a slice it's like a Pie Pizza
app he was like between January 1st and
January 11th our sales slump and he goes
on January 12th that's National quitting
day and he goes we see alltime high
sales on for people ordering pizza
because everyone from their New Year's
resolution is giving in on January 12th
that's where that's where it ends 11
days that's wild we owned a ton of uh
Planet fitnesses uh back in my PE days
and that like first 10 days of the year
is like rain maker season like you're
just sitting there just like watching
the fees pour in like praying to the
rain gods for all the money that's
coming in and then inevitably those
people just don't end up going to the
gym but they still pay yeah they still
bu dud PL of Fitness business model dude
they model is like yeah you get you get
like 10,000 members for a gym and maybe
like you know 5 10% of them actually
like regularly use it so the equipment
doesn't have to get refreshed that often
it's like I mean it's an incredible
business model all right here's a
question for sahill so we didn't even
mention this but sahill sahill you
mentioned that you were a baseball
player I was a runner all through high
school and college the baseball players
were usually the douches who made fun of
the runners because of our shorts and
about a year ago you got you got into
running you made all these Grand claims
about these times that you were going to
run you said you're going to break 18 in
the 5K you're going to break I was like
you're an idiot dude you don't know what
the hell you're talking about turns out
you were completely right you nailed all
of it you you you crushed it and running
and someone asked what the biggest so so
at this point by the way you're a pretty
like you're like a pretty successful
runner for like in the weekend Cate in
the weekend warrior category you're like
top top in that category uh which is uh
sounds like a left-handed compliment
that's not what it that wasn't supposed
to be that it was that was a I take that
that was a compliment someone said
what's the uh biggest surprise Sills
learned from getting more into running
honestly it goes back to what you said
like when I was um when I was in high
school like I thought Runners were nerds
um and in my mind it was like the
nerdiest sport like I couldn't imagine
running or like being IND I was like ah
it's not you know it's not a team sport
like it's not it's it doesn't seem hard
whatever and I have developed
unbelievable respect for endurance
athletes and for runners from having
gone through this because I mean know a
few reasons first off the training is so
many hours and so monotonous and you
have to fall in love with the long slow
runs like you know in baseball it was
all intensity so you can get excited
about you know like a really fast Sprint
uh you know I was a pitcher so like a
bullpen session or whatever but with
running like if you're going to be a
marathoner you have to love the 22 Mile
at a like 830 Pace just zero fun like
you have to fall in love with that and
be willing to do that over and over over
and over again in order to become a
great amateur or to become Elite you
know like on Nick's level and above and
you have to do it consistently over a
long period of time and then the second
one is just like the mental fortitude to
pull through a race is badass like it
hurts so bad I mean I would argue that
the 5K is the most painful like I did so
my my PRS were the 257 Marathon which
was painful but in like a your legs are
cramping kind of way where you just need
to like grit your teeth to the Finish I
ran the 459 mile which honestly didn't
hurt that bad because it was too short
to hurt like it was just it was over
before it could really start to hurt it
was like you're breathing really fast
but didn't hurt that bad but the 5K
which I ran
1752 was like excruciating pain
absolutely like the last five laps of
that were the most miserable experience
maybe of My Life um just like past your
lactate threshold awful and the mental
fortitude that Runners have and that
endurance athletes have to grind through
that I now like I no longer think
Runners are nerds I think it is legit
badassery and especially when it's like
a runner that has body weight on them I
think it's unbelievable well the the the
the runner like the the runner has
evolved over the years too like now
running's become so popular in the past
couple years it's it's do you think it's
because of people like you I mean I
think I think that you've created like a
huge trend of these like it's it's now
Macho to be a runner yeah I do think
that like covid and the pandemic
definitely contributed to a lot of that
where gyms were closed down and this is
why a lot of my content actually started
growing is because I was pumping out
running content for like a year and a
half before the pandemic hit and then
pandemic hits all these Gyms close
people have nowhere to to work out and
train and they need it for their
physical health but also their mental
health so people start running and
looking for running content and my
content blew up during that time because
everyone was looking for how to run
especially you know people who are
focused on strength now transitioning
and evolving towards
running but I I mean I
think running has become cooler because
there's a different look to running now
like you can carry more weight you can
look like a bodybuilder you can look
like a strength athlete and there's
these different parts of running that
exist like the ultra scene has come up
and I didn't know what ultra running was
years ago and you have like these badass
disruptive races like have you guys
heard of the speed project no what's
that no so speed project is like this
underground race that
happens and you start in LA and then it
goes to Las Vegas there's no Spectators
there's no rules you just get there as
fast as possible and it's a relay race
so you have a team of I say like maybe
six people I think it's like 300 miles
and someone has to be running all the
time [__] but it's like super disruptive
really like aggressive inyour face look
and feel it's badass and then you have
racist like have you guys heard of the
Barkley marathons no what are these dude
you guys you guys need to watch this
documentary like tonight it's called
where dreams go to die oh I have seen
this and this race happens in
Tennessee it's I think there there's
five loops and it's run by this guy
named
Laz and you can't have a GPS watch you
don't
have uh like any sort of sense of where
the route is you're given a map and the
map has points on it there's no Trail
and you're given a bib number so say
your bib number is 13 on this map you
have to go find all these points before
you come back to the checkpoint and at
each point on the appap is a book and
you have to pull out the corresponding
page with your bib number and bring it
back to Laz after each Loop to be able
to go out and start again and I think
there were like six years where no one
finished no one won yeah it's like 15
runners in 38 years dud that sounds like
a pain in the butt I'm not trying to
learn how to read maps I just want to
look good naked like by the way like
running to to Nick's Point running has
definitely changed in public perception
like I just more and more now I'm like I
used to think oh okay lifting like
deadlifting to me I'm like oh it's so
Primal deadlifting like you got to pick
a car up off of your wife or off of your
kid like you got to get it up off of
them in order to save their life and now
I I add running to that where I'm like
if you can't go run like super fast to
go call for help when someone's in
trouble like that's super Prime Ultimate
like you got to pick the car up and then
you got to go run two miles to get help
from like the nearest aid station we had
Scott Galloway on uh Nick Scott always
is like big successful entrepreneur
whatever and he um he said something
that was was brilliant he's like a he's
like a poet he's really good with words
and he said um he goes my fitness regime
I want to be able to kill and eat most
everyone in a room or outrun them uh I
was like I like that that's great I love
that that sounds very like a very
practical way to to exercise I enjoy
that have you seen Theo vaugh on Joe
Rogan talking about uh who he would eat
in a plane crash if you if you haven't
seen it it's like one of the funniest
theovon clips I've ever seen um let me
uh all right I'll ask one or two more uh
the so someone asked do you guys um do
you guys religiously stick to your
programming and do you ever create the
programming yourself it really depends
on for me like what I'm training for if
I have a very specific goal then my
training program is specialized to get
to that specific goal so like for my my
Marathon prep working with Jeff
Cunningham like he would give me my
workouts for the week and I would hit
those workouts to a te I wouldn't miss
or skip anything I mean there there's
been times where Jeff has accidentally
sent me in my workouts with wrong paces
and I look at him be like oh [__] this
team's fast and I go out and hit him
he's said what are you doing I'm like
you sent this over to me he's like oh
that's a typo so like if you if he if
you said the program when I'm in a a
prep I'm doing whatever you tell me to
do but outside of that I have a lot of
flexibility like today I woke up and I
was thinking how's my body feel how far
do I want to run I went and ran ran 10
miles sometimes in the middle of the run
like two to three miles in I decide how
far I'm going to run based off my feel
that's called Auto regulation so you
adjust your training programming based
off your recovery and how you're feeling
and how well you slept and all those
things so a lot of my training now as
flexible but it's not as rigid because I
don't have a specific competition goal
at the moment what about you
saho I need someone else to write the
programs for me otherwise I don't take
them seriously and I need to pay for
them um I found because when I pay for
something I take it way more seriously
so my um my marathon training I had no
program I was just running with my
neighbor um Brian Maza who's also a I I
know Nick knows him also um he like a
fitness influencer and uh personality
that was really into hybrid training as
well so I started running with him had
no program and then uh I got connected
on text with Nick and I was like Nick I
want to run a sub three-h hour marathon
what's a workout I should do and Nick
replied and was like try doing this and
it was I don't think I'd run over like
16 miles at the time by the way and Nick
repli and said 22 Mile run it was 6
miles easy to warm up and then it was
four rounds of three at 6:30 with one at
710 float he was like if you can do that
you'll feel good about being able to run
sub3 and I had never done I mean I had
not come close to that but that weekend
I had the same thing as what you said
with your trainer Nick we're like I was
like all right I gotta go do that I
guess and so I went out and hit that um
and then I started following Nick's
Marathon program as a result um that got
me through it wow um I I do the same
thing by the way I've got a a guy that
does my programming here in Austin his
name is Jesse at Central athlete and
it's expensive I think I pay $400 a mon
month um and I only I I do everything
that I'm told because I'm paying money
for it and if I won't take it seriously
if I'm doing it or I wouldn't go my
intensity would be lower I'd like dude I
can't do this it's like well Jesse told
me I have to do it therefore I will do
it um all right last question do you get
nutrition coaching too I get nutrition
coaching yeah I use my body tutor um
it's basically a service when I was like
really into it I would call them for
five minutes every single day and they
would be like all right what's the plan
today where like you have like a
quarterly plan you're like I want to
lose weight gain weight I don't want to
eat this I do want to eat this whatever
and there's like all right what's what
what's your plan today in order to hit
your goals um and you and they you'd
have to like show them and then they
review your My Fitness Pal every night
and it's like all right you're you're
doing you're doing everything according
to plan so it kind of guilt guilts me
into doing it but it also teaches me
like like I didn't know that you had to
get a gram of protein per body power
pound or per pound of body weight like I
didn't know any of that [__] and so they
like educated me um track track tracking
nutrition can be super beneficial for
people just getting into Health Fitness
just teaches them about serving sizes
and macronutrients and total calories
well I started weighing my food after I
saw Nick you did it on some of your
videos you were like and I thought
weighing your food was like cumbersome
but like I just saw you like just have a
bowl on top of the scale and when you
were pouring the chicken in there like I
just need about half a pound and you
just pour it in there like oh cool that
was really simple and easy he just
poured it right into the bowl and put it
in microwave and it was like a very easy
thing to track so I started doing it
after I saw your videos actually yeah I
don't track my nutrition right now but I
still weigh my food just for like
serving size
allocation yeah and now I know but now I
just buy like like if I buy red meat I
buy it by the pound and I know that a
pound of red meat reduces to7 and I know
what's in s of uh you know ground beef
OR7 of chicken and so yeah that's how I
do a lot of it now uh for weighing last
question um this is from me I'm actually
curious who influences you guys and what
sources do turn to for like like for
example there's this guy um what's the
guy on uh I think his name is biolane on
Instagram what's his name yeah Lane
Norton lanan great so like I like he's
like you know New York Times did an
article where they're like now everyone
has their own Fitness Guru who they
trust and so like hberman is like a guy
for someone you're a guy for someone
probably where I'm like if they say this
I do what they say who are your your
gurus your Fitness guys that you trust
for health and nutrition and what
sources do you
use Lane Norton is definitely one for me
what I like about
Lane is like if anyone's ever saying
something and it seems so ridiculous and
bold and new and fresh I will literally
go over to Lane's platform and wait for
him to do a response because he
typically does I love his carnivore
stuff and like the guy who says like
vegetables are bad for you like it's
great yeah Lane has like a really
holistic science-based approach to
health and nutrition he also has a
really good app called carbon that is
great for people who want to track their
nutrition and and reach their Fitness
goal like fitness-wise
I follow Lane I listen to some huberman
stuff I'm typically just like I don't I
don't have one person I'm I'm following
for Fitness and Nutrition I'm kind of
just like having a pulse and feeling
what's out there and then if I hear
about something I'll go do my own
research so I'll read the actual
articles in peer- reviewed literature to
see what what do you use for that have
you heard of I've been using perplexity
for that it's been kind of cool for it's
like a chat gbt for studies interesting
perplexity yeah I have it bookmarked
here perplexity and it's uh uh they do a
bad job of explaining what it is
but it they basically review tons of
different studies so you don't have to
read all of them and so you can ask you
can ask it a question of like is
aspartame proven to give cancer and I'll
say like well of all these studies
here's what it here's what they here's
the summary I'll check that out L Lane
has one called reps I also use
examine.com same love them examine.com
is really good and then I'll just go
like to PubMed PubMed and just like read
the the articles there from like fit
that's where I'm like pulling a lot of
my info outside of
Fitness um just like audiobooks like
whenever I'm running I'm typically
listening to an audio book and that's
crazy to me that's insane to me that you
do that you you can't do that dude no
like a I don't pay attention and B like
it like you usually what I like to do is
uh I like when I go for a run I know how
many I like beat uh beat per minute song
you know songs that are a certain beat
per minute and so my stride will go to
that that beat per minute you know what
I mean which is typically like like
around 80 be or 85 beats per minute I
used to do that when I first started
running I would do that but yeah I'll
listen to an audio book in like 10 miles
I forget I'm running for 10 miles like I
just I listened to an audiobook during
the marathon I did the exact same thing
what I listened to uh the Martian Andy
we uh the Sci-Fi dude you guys are so
weird that is so weird to me dude you
know what book I I just finished up that
like I can't recommend enough it's
called trust by Henry Cloud if you guys
haven't read that yet or heard of it
it's I mean maybe it's just hitting me
at like the right time of my life but it
is a powerful good book what is it it's
all about like how to evaluate
relationships and Trust how to regain or
rebuild trust when you've been betrayed
what to look for in in in trusting
someone a lot of times we think that
trust is someone who just like won't lie
steal or
cheat so like we'll hire people or bring
people onto our team who meet those
requirements oh they don't lie steal or
cheat I can trust them or can we trust
them in the capacity of the role that
we're expecting them to perform dude
this is serial killer [__] that you can
listen to a self- health book uh while
you're like while you're like running a
marathon I think that's so weird uh like
I would read this B you went no
headphones for the marathon right Nick
yeah yeah I didn't no
headphones that's what Ballers do sahill
like if if you yeah that is what Ballers
I grew real Runners will definitely give
you [__] yeah if you like go to a cross
country practice or something and like
you go run with headphones on like the
the hardcores will totally mock you but
I do it anyway because I'm like this is
fun for me I'm doing what I want I'm not
GNA be hard was what Nick said at the
beginning by the way which is like when
you uh if you publicly State you're
going to hit some sort of like goals um
the running like the the running
hardcores will definitely talk crap and
troll you until you post proof that you
actually did it and then you kind of
like have earned enough clout like I
sort of feel like everyone made fun of
me for getting into running and then I
like posted some actual verifiable stats
and now you you know now I'm like a
solid amateur and people can't really
make fun of you anymore so now you've
like you've like earned the respect of
the crew like the cool kids in the in
the cafeteria so now like they can't
come beat you up that's a real thing
that actually happens yeah what's your
what's your answer to that um what's my
answer to uh where I go to yeah and who
influences you who's like your your
person I mean I grew up um so my
baseball training I was the first client
of this guy named Eric cresy who has now
become pretty famous um he's the
performance coach for the Yankees but is
now like the Major League Baseball
strength guy like trains Max jurz or
Justin verland or all of like the who's
who of baseball and guy's the worst
person to get Fitness advice from that's
like the fattest
sport no he was like the um he was the
first guy to like really bring strength
and performance training to baseball so
it was that it was like the fat guys or
the steroid era guys who were just
Meatheads and he brought like True
Performance training to the sport which
now is like the real driver of why every
guy throws 100 miles an hour like guys
are hitting absolute tanks all the time
like he was really the pioneer of that I
mean he's been on like Tim Ferris
podcast he's really really big time and
a close friend incredible uh and then
there's this guy Ben Bruno who is like a
celebrity trainer um pretty Instagram
presence and he's more of the like stuff
for regular people to actually Implement
in their life um training and um I I
just love that stuff because it's kind
of a cool blend of the like more extreme
things that I like doing with the
actionable stuff that people can
actually take as advice yeah B Bruno
he's got like the uh like the everyday
rip guy
Vibe he he's super super strong
functionally um and trains like insane
legit celebrities out of like a 150
square foot gym in his garage yeah
here's him with J timberlink yeah
timberlink is like one of his one of his
good friends rolls up there and trains
with them he's he's incredible um and
then on diet stuff there's this guy um
Zach I think rousel is how you pronounce
his last name he's like the flexible
dieting lifestyle is his Instagram
handle and he just posts like insane
macro recipes basically um things that
are like delicious but don't completely
screw up your diet and I just I nerd out
on that kind of stuff he's he's Austin
Texas based yeah he's Austin based yeah
dude Nick you probably know like half
these guys I would bet I know I know
Zach I know Zach personally you know who
else is really good for like General
Health Information Health and Fitness in
information for people just getting
started as Jordan s Jordan yeah Jordan
SC so Jordan was an intern at Eric
cress's gym so Jordan is my year in high
school he went to Lincoln studbury High
School which was like our rival high
school and he was an intern at cr's gym
when I was was training there so I've
known Jordan since we were like we were
kids oh wow yeah he's he's he's got good
stuff by the way I Gary V's trainer I
saw that I just went to this guy the
flexible dieting lifestyle and I'm I'm
like typing all the in as you guys are
talking and I'll I'll do a little Flex I
go to follow this guy and it says follow
back oh
yeah that's awesome Zach is awesome the
protein ice cream recipes are like the
best thing in the world yeah he this is
a great Instagram this guy kills it do
you have a do you have a creamy at home
ninja creamy I do oh it's the best one
of our best purchases my wife and I like
every Saturday the ninja creamy you can
make like protein ice cream with it they
were they got popular based off of Tik
Tock early on and they like were sold
out for months and then they finally
came back on the market we purchased one
well I used to do that so what I do with
your so uh bpn so I like to do uh a
scent protein with just water and then I
use bpn to like eat and so like for
example I'll mix it with some type of
liquid and I'll microwave bpn and it's
almost like I'm eating like um I I don't
know I mean it's like a dessert because
you gave me the keyme pie one and then
you gave me a birthday cake one and I
think the birthday cake one is
discontinued and I would just we would
microwave it and just eat it and it was
like a A sule or something now I guess
I'll use bpn for this creamy Sam I will
change your life right now two cups of
whole milk like Fair life whole milk a
scoop of bpn vanilla uh maybe like two
tiny little packets of stevia and some
uh sugarfree vanilla pudding mix freeze
it overnight put it into the ninja
creamy and it is literally identical to
like a vanilla McDonald's McFlurry
really it comes out insane and then you
can put a couple like Oreo thins in
there and get like a legit McDonald's
McFlurry that has like 40 grams of
protein and is gray for you dud this is
awesome I'm like literally writing all
this down and I just add the creamy to
my cart it will change your life I'm not
joking it is it is pretty wild I I did
it my first time and like I only mixed
it once and it came out I like what's
this yeah you got to go twice I did it
twice completely different thing the
after like one more mix Light Ice Cream
setting once open it up pour like a tiny
uh like a tablespoon of whole milk in
and then blend it on light ice cream
again and it makes the perfect
consistency all right I literally just
bought it off Amazon the creamy and I'll
I only have I gotta get bpn vanilla now
because I only did chocolate birthday
cake and key pie um I want to hear about
this 239 though I'm gonna nerd out on
this yeah so Nick you're trying to run
239 now for the marathon right no I just
did so you just did at cim which is the
California International Marathon that
was December 3rd I ran a
23920 and when I went into that prep I
was shooting for a sub
245 and and sub 24 5 is about a 615
minute per mile Pace ended up doing 605
minute per mile pace for all 26.2 of
those
miles can you just walk through your
progression on the marathon stuff
because I feel like I've seen a video so
I mean I only I started running in March
and someone mentioned your name as soon
as I started getting into running as
like the person that was pioneering this
whole idea of like hybrid athlete
whatever it's kind of become like an
invogue thing now but basically a guy
that can be both jacked and fit in
cardio things not CrossFit like actual
you know strength related stuff and then
and then running and I remember seeing a
video of you like a 4H hour marathon
maybe um and your progression from that
to running maybe sub three for the first
time can you just walk through like what
your progression has been from start to
finish on the different marathons you've
done yeah well first off when when you
and I first started talking and you said
you wanted to do a sub three for your
first marathon I thought he was crazy
when he said that dude so did I I was
like man that's I think I even told you
like that's a bold move but you did it
so congratulations on that um but yeah
my my my Marathon progression so my
first marathon was in
2018 it was about a year after I got out
of the military and what's funny is the
day I got out of the military I said I
would never run a day in my life again
and about a year later was running my
first marathon and here we are like
thousands of miles later but 2018 Austin
marathon I ran a
357 which was just an absolute dumpster
fire but you weighed like 225 right
that's was like 225 I didn't have a a
training program I was a bodybuilder
like I was just I just wanted to be as
big and yolked as
possible ran this
marathon after mile 16 I hit the wall it
was just all downhill from there a year
later I signed up for the Austin
marathon again same training program
which was lack there up of and I ran a
4H hour 15-minute Marathon so I I ran 18
minutes slower than the previous
year and then after that I signed up for
my first Iron Man trained for an Iron
Man did Iron Man Florida actually
started to learn what it takes to build
endurance and get better at endurance
events and races you broke 12 hours in
that one yeah I did my IR Iron Man
Florida in
1128 but I ran the marathon in four
hours and 4 minutes so the reason that
was so kind of significant was I looked
back at my previous two marathons I was
like man after I just swam and biked and
then ran I was able to run a pretty
decent Marathon so I told myself I want
to run sub three and that was the goal
and I I I posted this online I said I'm
doing a sub three hour
marathon and the internet trolls and
activity just blew up I mean there are
Forums on let's run run there are Forums
on on Reddit everyone was like this guy
will not run a sub three hour marathon
so then I signed up for the Austin
marathon
again I I followed a training program it
was a better prep but even in my head I
was like I'm not in sub three shape but
at the starting line I told myself you
can mentally out will anything I was
like if I just like I can mentally
overcome the physical weakness that I
have to run the sub three hour marathon
and what's sub three is sub3 650 per
mile I think 651 is like
25959 like if you sneak in under one
second and the only reason I know that
is because of exactly what Nick said
about mine that everyone was like dude
there's no way so I knew in my mind like
I just have to keep this under 651 my
watch base and I'm gonna be fine see I
like banking time so I always like I
like saving time so at the end if I need
it I have it which is the opposite of
what like real Runners tell you to do I
did the same thing by the way like I
went out way too fast and then was just
like hanging on for deer life doing the
math in my head of like okay if I run
like a 10-minute mile here I'm still
going to make it I'm still because
there's like they call it the wall the
wall is basically I think it's like when
you burn 1,00 or 2200 calories or
something like that and you start going
into what's it called where you like
start using muscle as energy I believe
orad of car yeah yeah yeah and that's
when that wall is where you're like I
can't go any further usually that's in
like mile 20 right yeah ranges you know
based off the individual like your
conditioning your experience glycogen
stores how how fast you burn through
your body's
energy so I went out that Austin
marathon with a goal of running sub
three I went out way too fast and within
the first six miles I knew I wasn't
going to do SUB three like I in the
first six miles I was done for the
Austin marathon is not flat it's it's
Hills it's it's like a horrible PR
course no one PRS that I know of at the
Austin
marathon so then the remainder of that
race I was just holding on ended up
running 3:24 so 24 minutes over sub
three everyone on the internet that
doubted me loved it and I went into
another training block immediately after
that race was done I actually did a real
prep this time had a really solid Coach
Jeff
Cunningham and I ended up running a
marathon a year later in 2 hours 56
minutes 27 seconds so that was the first
time I went sub three then a year later
I did the Buffalo New York Marathon in
248 and then just recently December 3rd
2023 I ran a
23920 which is a 605 God mile Pace what
weight were you I was 195 pounds oh my
God that's ridiculous at 195 and was
ridiculous at any at any body weight but
it's insane at 195 were you still
squatting and benching while you're I
mean were you you still strong I I I
took a lot of time off strength training
during that prep so for like 13 weeks
leading up to that race I was still
lifting here and there but I wasn't
lifting legs heavy I wasn't lifting even
upper body really heavy I was just
getting some movement in just to
maintain and feel good but the priority
was was running because what a lot of
Runners don't realize is like so 239
that's that's impressive that's very
impressive but it's more impressive that
you're doing it at your body weight that
is that is that is like out of this
world I um I got dinner one time
recently with this guy named Josh Kerr
do you guys know who Josh Kerr is unless
you're a running nerd you don't know who
he is but he won the world he won the
World Championships recently in the 1500
meter he's like a 345 Miler so one of
the fastest milers ever whatever but
he's pretty big for a Miler for a normal
human being you think he's skinny but
for a Miler he's big and I started
talking to him and I was like you're
pretty big uh how'd you do this he goes
man he's from uh Scotland I think he
goes when I I came to America when I was
17 to go to college and I was training
for the mile and I but I wasn't used to
having fast food and like having
restaurants open 24 hours a day and so I
got fat like my first semester there and
I weighed 200 pounds and I broke the
mile when I was 17 or 18 that year when
I weighed 200 pounds he goes I think I
own the world record for the fattest
sub4 Mile and like 200 lb for like just
a guy who's 6 foot that's not huge but d
to run that time or the time even that
uh you're running or even sahill you're
pretty big too for running those times
with that weight that's just like
inconceivable not only because it's hard
but what's inconceivable is that you're
not getting hurt running 50 to 80 miles
a week leading up to it that's what's
like in my mind the most impressive part
here yeah mean when I first started
running I I had a lot of
injuries just because my my body
mechanics weren't super efficient so
I've had knee
injuries uh quads ankles shins calves
like everything but now as I've I've run
longer with more miles my body has
become pretty efficient at Form and
Function and I rarely get injured
anymore unless I do like a an ultra
marathon I had two um you know from my
training I just had two like random life
lesson type things from the running that
I'm curious Nick if you've experience
these one was before my Marathon I was
trying to figure out like how to just
like mentally take on um the goal of
running sub three for it and how to
think about like if I'm six miles into
the race and I realize I'm not going to
hit it how to make sure I still finish
the race and don't just like mentally
completely lose it and this marathoner
told me that for every single race or
anything that you're going after you
want to have basically three goals he
was like you have your a goal which is
the main thing you're trying to hit and
then you have a b goal which is like
just slightly worse and then you have a
c goal which is just like finish the
Damn Race and you can always like you
lock in on your a goal from the start
but if you start falling off that and
realize you're not going to hit it you
need something to fall back on that
keeps you motivated when you're in it
and so you have your B goal and then the
C goal is just get to the finish line
and I have taken that and like run with
it in every area of life now like no
matter what it is if you have a fitness
goal like a daily Fitness goal you want
to you know run every day and work out
every day it's good to have that a goal
but the reality is that like [__] hits
the fan sometimes like your kid is up
all night or you know like you have a
problem at home or something at work
pops up and so having that idea of like
what is the B goal maybe it's a slightly
lower version and then the C goal is
like I'm just going to go for a walk and
get 15 minutes of movement in that has
helped me so much in terms of just like
navigating the vagaries of life that
inevitably hit when you know you're not
going to have your perfect day every
single day yeah it's like the mindset of
like all or nothing so like you see so
many
people at every marathon every
race it's very applicable to anything
else in life but you see these Elite
runners go out and as soon as they fall
off of pace they drop out they just fall
to the side and I was actually talking
to Ken R out a few weeks ago when he was
on uh my podcast and now he lives right
down the road for me here in in
Nashville but he was telling me when he
did Kona Iron Man years and years and
years ago
go during the race he realized he wasn't
going to hit the time he wanted so he
just dropped down to the race and he him
and his family traveled to Hawaii for
this race so there's a lot of time
effort energy money going into it he
dropped down to the race and he said it
was like his greatest regret ever so he
he forced himself to go back the next
year for for Redemption just to prove to
himself that he could do it but I think
the the feelings the emotions and just
everything that that's created when you
quit something and drop out because you
weren't on Pace for that egg goal I mean
that's like self-destruction that hurts
so much more than not actually finishing
the race the other thing that's funny to
me about uh all Runners that I feel like
they've gone through you said it like
with your first marathon or when you
left the military you were like I'm
never going to run again I'm done with
this it's like uh it's like women after
they have um after they have babies
there's like that chemical that gets
released that makes them forget how much
it hurts going through child birth I
think the same thing happen with running
it just is like a little more delayed
like when I finished my Marathon I was
like [__] this I'm never running another
Marathon my like that was the most
painful thing I ever experien like the
last six miles I wouldn't wish that on
my worst damn enemy in the world and
then like two weeks later I'm like like
which one should I sign up for next year
like I Gotta Go 249 I gotta do this yeah
I mean it's I'm the same way with Ultras
like I finished an ultra and I'm out for
two weeks I can't walk my toenails are
falling off and I talk to my wife I'm
like this is this was stupid why did I
do this
I'm useless I can't help on at home and
I find myself signing up for another
Ultra shortly after dude your Ultra
documentary was so good I I remember I
like had I subscribed for like the
premiere so I was like sitting at my TV
waiting for it to come out it was an
hour long about Leadville I think right
yeah uh it was so good I remember I was
like one of the first ones I was like
all right it's coming up at this time
Sarah let's sit down and watch it and
what's crazy about you is like there's
this whole thing where these people who
talking cliches or like every Media or
every company should be a media company
yada yada Y and the thing is they mostly
suck at it you're actually one of the
few guys that has like your supplements
they meet I don't know what the grade is
but you know I know uh I've talked to
you and I talked to other people about
it and your competitors will be like
yeah bpn they they meet this particular
grade they are of high quality but you
also you nail that the supplement thing
but then you also are nailing the media
thing and no one else or very few other
people are doing that where they're
you're actually really nailing it it's
almost You could argue that your media
is even better than the supplements
because supplements like I don't know
how the industry works but it seems like
yeah they like these five are great but
your media is awesome I appreciate that
you had like it looked like you had
three or four guys following you around
the whole time your wife was there I
feel like I know her because of of the
videos and then she was following you on
Instagram or and talking about your
splits and these guys have these
beautiful cameras it was just like it it
was a great documentary how many views
did that have the Leadville doc now has
I think one and a half million it was so
good man it was so good are you did you
come up with that storyline or did you
just hire a good a good team that's my
creative director Jordan in house here
where's he from Jordan is from Ohio
geographically but he was just when I
met him he was employee number four at
bpn and he was filming for another
YouTuber when I met him as a Freel
answerer and I was looking for a
videographer at the time because this
was
2019 at the time I was still filming and
editing all my own videos that's crazy
that's a [__] ton of work I mean all I
did all literally all I did was
work and 2019 was the first time I was
able to bring some on on but I was
looking for like over a year for the
right person I would fly people down
they would stay with me i' meet them
we'd film something it just didn't feel
right so I didn't to it met
Jordan felt right he moved down creative
director he led my content for a while
then he went and led bpn content for a
while and now he's back working directly
on my content again but he came up with
the
storyline the the whole production The
Scouting the editing process obviously
we had a lot of guys on the team
supporting that editing and and filming
and production but Jordan LED that that
project
we just launched the last man standing
Ultra that he led and created with Ian
Rodriguez here on my team and we posted
the cim race video Monday but yeah
Jordan is a super talented creative
what's your how much are you spending
per year on a team for content and are
you able to are you tracking the ROI or
is this just like a thing where you're
like I'm pretty sure it's working it's
up I'm pretty sure it's working I mean
our our media team
is I mean with videog just videographers
photographers we
have 10 but then we have our social team
and a lot of my business
decisions as like as an entrepreneur one
thing I've learned and I think we were
talking about this when when you were on
my podcast a few months
ago is that I make a lot of my decisions
and I've made a lot of my decisions in
business based off of intuition and gut
feeling I never looked at the p&l I
never looked at the balance sheet if I
had this feeling that it was working and
I could feel momentum and I had a pulse
on it I was just like keep keep spending
keep hiring then finally at one point I
I hired operators a CFO a CEO and
they're like hey we got to put some some
guard rails around this but like all of
my decisions in business have been
intuition gut if it feels right I'm
going to do it I have I have a feeling
there's going to be an Roi I might not
be able to measure it but I can
subjectively tell if it's going to work
or it is working is it separate at all
like the Nick bear Fitness platform and
your personal social media is that
separate from bpn as like a functional
entity or are the people like the
videographers the 10 people is that all
under bpn yeah the whole process has has
changed significantly over the last
couple years so originally it was all
one team
and then at one point we separated out
where I have now have the Nick bear
Fitness business and then the bear
performance nutrition business so there
were like two separate teams and the
Nick bear Fitness business is your app
right your app and your channel yeah
it's like my my content my
IP uh my my channel my training app
stuff like that I used to do brand deals
I don't do any brand deals anymore more
dude Hoka should have been paying you
like seven figures a year I bought hokas
because of you because I saw I was like
oh big guy wears hokas hokas is thing
the amount of the amount of hoko renc
cons I sold when I first started running
has to be absolutely ridiculous so just
talking about the separation we
separated out Nick bear Fitness team and
bpn team for a
while really it it made no sense uh of
what we were doing and why we're doing
it just I just thought it was the
professional move to take in that next
step and stage of business now we've
brought it all back into
one entity I still have the Nick bear
Fitness business but everyone that is
working on media is on bpn payroll is a
bpn team member and all the content
we're
creating is in the hope of building the
supplement business now the teams are
separated working on different projects
like I have my creative director Jordan
who's leading my content Ian who's
working on my content Everett who's a
podcast producer and then we have
videographers creatives that are working
on just bpn stuff but there's definitely
crossover and the lines are blur
blurrier than they used to be do you
think that dings your valuation if you
ever wanted to sell the company because
it's so tied onto you I don't know if it
it dings the valuation but I definitely
think that a process and a sale would
come with a whole lot of structure a lot
of I
IP IP negotiations and possibly
issues um I feel like it's less than you
think actually I um I was always
impressed so I had actually taken bpn
supplements before knowing you and had
no idea who you were or that you were
involved they had just like popped up as
one of the supplements I was taking
actually that's not the bulk you think
you think s that's the bulk of custom
honestly I have no idea I just remember
like back in my private Equity days we
looked at um on it you remember that I
don't know if it's still around on it
was selling and it was like they had a
huge exit well it was so tied to joean
and what was his name Aubrey um yeah
Aubrey Marcus and that was like when we
were looking at it private Equity guys
like that's their biggest fear is like
oh how involved are these two guys like
is it a key man risk all this stuff and
then ultimately they ended up getting to
an amazing exit with somebody and you
know they put guard rails around it they
get like keyman insurance or whatever it
is um but I I would I mean I'd be
interested to find out actually like run
a survey of your customers like What
proportion actually end up coming
through you and your media versus now
just like the flywheel is spinning SEO
is there um and the business kind of
just you know is self-propagating well
that's been the fear with my businesses
which is I don't want to make it me I
want to make it its own thing but me or
Nick or sahill like that gets initial
base but it's like at what point do you
when do you make the transition and it's
a that's a challenging there's a I don't
know the answer to that question and I'm
afraid of the repercussions of making
the wrong making the wrong choice you
know what I mean yeah that that's been a
topic of discussion for the last couple
years with us and trying to figure out
how to navigate that and for a while I
kept leading into okay well let's
separate in the hopes of building bpn
away from myself so that it's separate
and distinct and can stand on its own
but what I I found by doing that is the
the
separation created this loss of vision
and
brand so I've kind of just like flipped
my whole thought process on that and
said screw whatever happens in the
future and I'm G to lean fully back in
and I don't care really how it affects
valuation or the end process anymore I'm
just going to build a brand that I'm
really proud of and the way I want to
build it and whatever happens happens
and if someone comes knocking on my door
in the next couple years and says like
hey we love what you're doing let's talk
but if you don't like it you know I just
want to make sure I'm enjoying the
process and not building a business
based off of kpis and Milestones and I
bet you're I mean I have I have no idea
I've never seen you comment on this but
I would I would have to assume the app
that you have how much do you charge 50
bucks a month or something uh it's $1
199.99 a month so I would have to
imagine that's doing well too right I
mean I I make much more money outside of
bpn that I make personally with bpn yeah
I mean I I think it's killing it s have
you ever thought about doing it yeah I
mean that type of business model is
incredible right it's just like the
ultimate
scalability and you know as your
personal it just for you as you think
about reinvesting cash flows into your
brand building it just makes it it makes
it so much more dynamic because you can
run all of your media stuff at break
even if you want to like you can just
reinvest all the cash that you're
generating from YouTube ads from the app
from any of those things into creating
better and better content and create
this massive flywheel and just count on
bpn as the like long-term upside bet
yeah but if I had a bet I I bet you Nick
if I had a bet Nick has probably been
even though his net worth has
skyrocketed I if I had to bet you'd live
you've lived relatively poor compared to
the net worth that you've created cash
flow poor and now you probably taste
this and you're like okay finally I can
afford like uh to live like I want to
live as as opposed to just living on
$80,000 a year yeah I mean for the
first I I didn't take any money out of
the business for the first five years
what do you get like just like a like a
army or you get like a military stien or
something yes it work it worked well
because started the business
2012 2017 is the year I transitioned out
of the army so I actually had to start
paying myself then me and my brother who
moved down from Pennsylvania to help us
build the business
we signed our first Warehouse lease that
year it was the first year we hit seven
figures in
revenue and it was also like the most
challenging year in my entire life
because I didn't know anything about
financing inventory I didn't know
anything about leveraging debt I didn't
know anything about taking out business
loans or utilizing lines of credit cash
flow is an absolute nightmare the only
money I thought I had to spend was the
money that was in the bank account we
had no terms with manufacturers like 20
2017 was arguably the the worst and
hardest year of my life but also the
best year of my life that if I could go
relive any year right now it'd be that
year that's insane that's one thing by
the way like just the the time frame on
all of this I feel like people don't
appreciate time as a lever for growth on
anything um as much as they should and
actually like people in Fitness and
athletes understand it better because
they understand that like growing slowly
is the game and just getting better
slowly like when I look at your YouTube
channel and go to most popular videos a
bunch of these videos like you've been
at this for years and years there's like
six-year-old video four-year-old video
three-year-old video like eight-year-old
video the 10,000 calorie cheat day
challenge like some of this stuff you've
just been add it and I know you just
said it you were editing these like you
were actually on the ground spending the
like 100 hour weeks doing this stuff for
a long long time it wasn't like you all
of a sudden popped up and had this
unbelievable you know production quality
that you have today so I I also just
think like appreciating time as a lever
for growth on these fronts is
incredible that is one one thing that's
been a powerful skill for myself over
this last decade plus is just the
consistency at which I've just kept
doing the thing but even the one thing
Sam and I talked about when he was on my
podcast I think you you were going to do
like a speech and you you were back in
like the green room before going out to
the speech and talking to all these high
worth individuals who are super powerful
and they're all sitting there super
insecure and scared and nervous and like
yeah they're like holy [__] these people
aren't any more secure confident or
better than me and I think once you
realize that that I have all the skills
that I need to take whatever is I want
to take to the top I just have to apply
it because I used to think and I went
through this phase where I like okay
I'll get this business I'll get this
thing to this this level but at some
point I'm not going to be smart enough
so I'm going to have to
Outsource people to come in and take it
from where I build it to where it needs
or can go and sometimes you do that but
you don't have to and I've realized that
there's no one smarter than me that's
going to take this business to the level
it needs to go I just have to be super
consistent at this approach for a long
period of time and it's GNA pay off in
dividends but you did hire a CEO I think
what are you a year into to that a
little over a year yep how's that it's
been great I
mean the the main reason I wanted to
step out of the CEO role and I I wasn't
actively looking to hire a
CEO but cat came into the
business first is kind of just an
advisor and then she joined as the chief
Revenue officer leaning into more
operations and then we just had a
conversation one day I was like hey
would you ever want to be CEO cuz I
really just want to like focus on
creating content and brand
building and she's like yeah if you want
me to be CEO I'll be CEO so we made the
switch because the business got to a
point in a size where I wasn't spending
my time on the things that I was
passionate about anymore I was spending
my time on like people management and
lawsuits and Retail and finances and p&l
and balance sheets and I was
like this is all like super critical
important stuff but I don't love it I
want to focus on what I love and that's
creating content that's building brand
that's getting people jacked up that's
talking about the products it's working
on new product
Innovation and that's why I wanted to
make that change which has been like
much harder than I thought it would be
and I'm only now a year in of that
transition really finding my Lane but
this last year for me has been an
interesting one dude and it's hard so so
I I have a CEO too we'll be at one year
in a couple months and it's hard because
you want to be a good I don't know what
it's called a good partner with your CEO
where you want them to make mistakes and
you want them to you know put their
flavor and stuff because you got to let
a CEO do that but then at the same time
you're like but I already did all this
and I can tell you what the outcome of
this is going to be or uh you know it's
just like it's really it's a it's a it's
like getting married where you and but
not living together right away and so
you get married and then you move in and
you're like oh you're [__] quit
leaving the cap off the toothpaste and
it's like well no you can't like [__]
about little stuff you got to let them
do what they want to do you know what I
mean it's like kind of weird it's like a
it's like a weird there's it's a weird
thing but you have to learn how to like
manage each other and it's and it is a
challenge but when it works it's hard
it's it's the best at any point do you
feel the need to jump back into the CEO
role well in my when I get pissed off
I'll be like
I gotta do this and then I'll get like
end of week or end of month updates and
I'm like oh my God Jordan is so much
better at me than all of these things
and I and and also like I would have
done this different this different this
different and those three things I
probably would have been wrong about so
like the the name of the game isn't
being right 100% of the time the name of
the game is being right for the right
things most of the time and I just had
to like kind of like have empathy and
put myself in his shoes and that helped
a lot but uh no like when I on a bad day
when I get pissed off I'm like I should
do this and then 99% of the time I'm
like you are more talented than I am at
so many things I cannot do this yeah I
think sometimes too when you're when
you're far removed from the position for
an extended period of time you forget
all the bad things you have to used to
deal with and you only remember the good
like man I kind of miss this and you get
exposed to all the the things the bad
things that you don't miss too much no
you got it you run with it
it also kind of I just before you jump
forward from that Sam it um it also
differs greatly between like a true
business operations Endeavor and a
creative Endeavor like you couldn't step
away and truly have a CEO just like
running your content apparatus because
it would lose it would lose the like the
Nick soul that is in it that's in every
single piece of content that exists you
can like build your team around it but
you actually being in that creatively um
I think is so key there was this um I
think it was Jerry Seinfeld um did a
interview with I think it was like the
Harvard Business review and they uh they
asked him about the fact that him and
Larry David basically like wrote every
episode of Seinfeld and after nine years
they had basically burned out and so the
show just had to end because they had
burned out on doing it and the Harvard
Business Review was like could you have
hired McKenzie uh to come in and like
help you find a better model and design
something and Jerry Seinfeld said who's
McKenzie and they said it's a consulting
firm and Seinfeld responded uh are they
funny and and basically his point was
you don't like I don't need them if
they're not funny because the efficient
way of doing the creative thing is
actually the wrong way and what he said
is the right way is the hard way the
show was successful because they did it
the hard way they micromanaged every
single detail of the creative process
and they really had their soul in it and
so I think that like your creative
success and what has allowed all your
businesses to thrive are also
fundamentally tied to the fact that you
have your soul in every sing piece of
content that you guys are putting
together yeah I agree with that I think
sometimes entrepreneurship and building
a business and and founding and
Company from the outside looking in like
people make it seem easy so it's
romanticized and everyone's like oh I
could start a business I could do it and
then you finally do it and like you have
this passion around everything you're
building but then it gets hard and it
gets challenging and then it grows and
then you know your passions are
sidelined for the priorities other other
the for other parts of the
business but it's just maintaining that
consistent work ethic even when you're
working on things that you truly weren't
passionate about in the beginning but
you know it drives business and leads
you to an ultimate end goal well guys uh
I appreciate you coming on uh it was a
little impromptu but this is fun I just
like hanging out with you guys and and
learning um nick uh sahill I'm close to
sahill so I don't say this to him but
Nick I've uh I've looked up to you for a
while now and I appreciate you doing
this sahill I appreciate you doing this
too this is awesome no thanks guys
appreciate the opportunity all right
that's the
[Music]
pod